[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>>> THANK YOU, NEW YORK.
>> NEW YORK.
>> THINGS GOT PRETTY TOUGH HERE
THIS SUMMER.
>> BUT THROUGH IT ALL, WE STAYED
STRONG.
>> WE STAYED TOGETHER.
>> AND WE NEVER LOST WHO WE ARE.
>> BECAUSE WE ARE NEW YORK.
>> NEW YORK.
>> AND NO MATTER HOW HARD THINGS
GET --
>> WE ALWAYS GET THROUGH IT.
>> AND WE DO IT OUR WAY.
>> EACH AND EVERY ONE OF US
PLAYED A PART.
>> FROM THE NURSES WHO KEPT US
SAFE --
>> TO THE ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHO
KEPT FOOD ON OUR TABLE --
>> TO ALL THE NEIGHBORS WHO JUST
PITCHED IN.
>> YES, SOME THINGS ARE
DIFFERENT.
>> BUT MOST THINGS ARE EXACTLY
THE SAME.
>> BEAUTIFUL.
>> UNBREAKABLE.
>> ONE OF A KIND.
>> IF YOU'RE NOT FROM HERE, COME
SEE FOR YOURSELF.
>> THE MUSEUMS.
>> THE LANDMARKS.
>> AND THIS LADY.
>> SORT OF A DANCING OLDER
WOMAN?
>> NOT HOMELESS, JUST PERKY.
SHE HAS AN APARTMENT.
SHE'S JUST USUALLY OUTSIDE.
>> LIKE A RENT CONTROLLED
SITUATION.
>> SHE LIVES IN A 40-FLOOR
WALK-UP, SO ONCE SHE'S OUT,
SHE'S OUT.
>> SHE LIVED IN A STUDIO SINCE
SHE WAS 16, WHICH WAS 30 OR 100
YEARS AGO.
>> SHE'S NOT NOT A PROFESSOR AT
COLUMBIA.
>> UNTIL BROADWAY REOPENS SHE'S
PERFORMING HER ONE-WOMAN VERSION
OF "THE LION KING" IN THE PARK
EVERY DAY.
>> NEW YORK IS NOT A GHOST TOWN.
>> IT'S HIS TOWN.
IT'S HER TOWN.
>> AND IT'S DEFINITELY HER TOWN.
>> THANK YOU!
>> SO TODAY WE WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> BECAUSE NEW YORK WILL ALWAYS
BE NEW YORK.
>> AND WE'RE SO PROUD TO SAY --
>> THE PEOPLE JUST CRAZY ENOUGH
TO CALL THIS PLACE HOME WILL
ALWAYS BE HERE.
>> I LOVE NEW YORK!